in previous videos we took this
bivariate data and we calculated the
correlation coefficient and just as a
bit of a review we have the formula here
and it looks a bit intimidating but in
that video we saw all it is is an
average of the product of the z scores
for each of those pairs and as we said
if r is equal to one you have a perfect
positive correlation if r is equal to
negative one you have a perfect negative
correlation and if r is equal to zero
you don't have a correlation but for
this particular bivariate data set we
got an r of 0.946
which means we have a fairly strong
positive correlation
what we're going to do on this video is
build on this notion and actually come
up with the equation for the least
squares line that tries to fit
these points
so before i do that let's just visualize
some of the statistics that we have here
for these data points we clearly have
the four data points plotted but let's
plot the statistics for x so the sample
mean and the sample standard deviation
for x
are
here in red
and actually let me box these off in red
so that you know that's what is going on
here so the sample mean for x and it's
easy to calculate 1 plus 2 plus 2 plus 3
divided by 4 is 8 divided by 4 which is
2. so we have x equals 2 right over here
and then this is one sample standard
deviation above the mean this is one
sample standard deviation below the mean
and then we can do the same thing for
the y variables
so the mean is 3
and this is one sample standard
deviation for y above the mean and this
is one sample standard deviation for y
below the mean and visualizing these
means especially their intersection and
also their standard deviations will help
us build an intuition for the equation
of the least squares line so generally
speaking the equation for any line is
going to be y is equal to m x
plus b where this is the slope and this
is the y intercept for the regression
line we'll put a little hat over it so
this you would literally say y hat this
tells you that this is a regression line
that we're trying to fit to these points
first what is going to be the slope
well the slope is going to be
r
times the ratio between the sample
standard deviation in the y direction
over the sample standard deviation in
the x direction this might not seem
intuitive at first but we'll talk about
it in a few seconds and hopefully it'll
make a lot more sense but the next thing
we need to know is all right if we can
calculate our slope how do we calculate
our y-intercept well like you first
learned in algebra 1 you can calculate
the y-intercept if you already know the
slope by saying well what point is
definitely going to be on my line
and for a least squares regression line
you're definitely going to have the
point sample mean of x comma sample mean
of y so you're definitely going to go
through that point
so before i even calculate for this
particular example where in previous
videos we calculated the r to be
0.946 or roughly equal to that let's
just think about what's going on so our
least squares line is definitely going
to go
through
that point now if r were one if we had a
perfect positive correlation then our
slope would be the standard deviation of
y over the standard deviation of x so if
you were to start at this point and if
you were to
run your standard deviation of x and
rise your standard deviation of y well
with a perfect positive correlation
your line would look
like this
and that makes a lot of sense
because you're looking at your spread of
y over your spread of x if r were equal
to 1 this would be your slope standard
deviation of y over standard deviation
of x that has parallels to when you
first learn about slope change in y over
change in x here you're seeing the you
could say the average spread in y over
the average spread in x and this would
be the case when r is one so let me
write that down this would be the case
if r
is equal to one what if r were equal to
negative one it would look like this
that would be our line if we had a
perfect
negative correlation now what if r were
zero then your slope would be zero and
then your line would just be
this line y is equal to the mean of y so
you would just go through that right
over there but now let's think about
this scenario in this scenario
our r is
0.946 so we have a fairly strong
correlation this is pretty close to 1.
and so if you were to take
0.946 and multiply it by this ratio if
you were to move forward and x
by the standard deviation in x
for this case how much would you move up
in y
well you would move up r
times the standard deviation of y
and as we said if r was 1 you would get
all the way up to this perfect
correlation line but here it's 0.946
so you would get up about 95 percent of
the way to that and so our line without
even looking at the equation is going to
look something
like this which we can see is a pretty
good fit for those points i'm not
proving it here in this video
but now that we have an intuition for
these things hopefully you appreciate
this isn't just coming out of nowhere
and it's some strange formula it
actually makes intuitive sense let's
calculate it for this particular set of
data m is going to be equal to r
0.946
times the sample standard deviation of y
2.168
over the sample standard deviation of x
0.816
we can get our calculator out to
calculate that so we have
0.9
times 2.160
divided by
0.816
it gets us to
2.50 let's just round to the nearest
hundredth for simplicity here so this is
approximately equal to
2.50
and so how do we figure out the
y-intercept well remember we go through
this point so we're going to have
2.50 times our x mean so our x mean is 2
times 2 remember this right over here is
our x mean plus b
plus b
is going to be equal to our y mean our y
mean
we see right over here is three
and so what do we get we get three
is equal to
5 plus b 5
plus b
and so what is b well if you subtract 5
from both sides you get b is equal to
negative 2.
and so there you have it the equation
for our regression line we deserve a
little bit of a drum roll here we would
say y
hat the hat tells us that this is
equation for a regression line
is equal to 2.50
times
x
minus 2
and we are done